also ein 26-jähriger youtuber selbst
politiker ganz schön unter druck was ist
da los
darüber möchte ich jetzt mit einer
medienwissenschaftlerin sprechen frau
professorin judith ackermann ich grüße
sie
hallo er macht das ganze deutlich wie
sich die art der öffentlichen
politischen kommunikation verändert hat
und dass die alteingesessenen parteien
da nicht mithalten können
es zeigt auf jeden fall dass die
reichweite die eben auch in sozialen
medien produzierte bewegtbildformate
mittlerweile haben schon ausreichend ist
um auch druck auf traditionellere und
ein bisschen schwerwiegendere systeme
haben zu können also dass jetzt auch
überlegt wurde wie ist tatsächlich die
richtige form um darauf zu reagieren ist
ja schon deutlich geworden dass es einen
sehr großen druck gibt der einfach da
durchaus gut würde von wiso pc-markt der
generalsekretär der cdu hat sich jetzt
dafür entschieden oder hat gesagt man
wolle keine video schlag wir keinen
video krieg da steckt die cdu natürlich
auch in einem dilemma wie wäre denn
ihrer ansicht nach eine richtige
reaktion gewesen hätte die vielleicht
auch schon viel eher kommen können das
ist ja auch das was häufig jetzt schon
kritisiert wurde dass eigentlich um die
video reaktion jetzt quasi noch
auftreten zu lassen die wartezeit schon
zu lange gewesen wäre
insofern verwundert es jetzt auch nicht
so dass in den letzten letzten minuten
nochmal entschieden wurde das nicht zu
machen
das ist aber so also da wird sich ja
immer darauf berufen dass es eine
riesige video schlacht geben würde und
man gar nicht mehr in einen persönlichen
austausch kommen würde das würde ich
nicht vermuten aber natürlich wir haben
ja gesehen dass auch die videos wieder
weiter geteilt werden und wieder
verändert werden reaktionen darauf
produziert werden die auch in bewegtbild
formaten sind und das wäre ja was eine
eben darauf die sich die cdu dann hätte
eingelassen die sie dann nicht mehr so
kontrollieren kann wie sie es gern würde
und ich glaube das war schon auch die ja
eine der hürden weshalb sie gesagt hat
sie macht das nicht dann lassen sie uns
mal über die machart des rieso videos
sprechen
manch einer sprach von propaganda im
zeitalter des internets ist ja schon
teilweise heftig was da gesagt wird
allein die überschrift zerstörung der
cdu wie bewerten sie das
also letztlich
argumentiert er eigentlich oder es ist
ein ganz klassisches youtube video und
im sinne weil das geht sehr viel um
persönliche meinung und es wird eine
kombination aus externen quellen
integriert dann auch nochmal verfügbar
gemacht werden und es ist aber ja doch
tatsächlich eine person also ein kanal
der für eine person steht die letztlich
ihre meinung äußern kann und den diskurs
dann nochmal auch in den kommentaren
natürlich eröffnet insofern ist es für
das format relativ typisch in der länge
jetzt gar nicht so sehr als ich bin auch
nicht sicher ob tatsächlich von diesen
über fünf millionen menschen die das
video angesehen haben alle bis auf
minute 55 aktiv dabei geblieben sind
da ist es schon ein bisschen auch ein
ausreißer für seine so eine art von
video aber es zeigt eigentlich schon
auch ein bisschen wie die typische
machart ist von entsprechenden
youtube-videos und nutzt letztlich ja
bei ihm auch die reichweite die
generiert wurde über teilweise ja ganz
unpolitische themen auch als man macht
ja auch sehr viel challenges die in
richtungen gehen die jetzt erst mal gar
nicht mit politik in verbindung gesetzt
werden und dass es aber dann doch ein
wandel geben kann also dass man auch die
themen noch mal verändern kann und hat
aber ja dennoch die reichweite aber wie
groß ist bei so einer macht denn die
gefahr dass das user mit journalismus
verwechseln also da auch ausgewogenheit
zu erwarten ist
ja das ist immer ein bisschen die frage
natürlich auch der medienkompetenz der
personen die sich das jetzt an seen und
der beziehung die sie dann auch zu den
format schaffenden letztlich haben aber
es ist auf seinem kanal publiziert und
das ist ja letztlich dann schon auch ist
also er steht hinter den inhalten die er
dort jetzt eben präsentiert hat und man
sieht ja auch dass es jetzt in allen
klassischen medien noch mal aufgegriffen
wurde so das nicht eigentlich nicht die
chance besteht dass es für sich als eine
geschlossene form rezipiert wird sondern
es wird immer auch mit den
verschränkungen die es in andere formate
bekommen hat gesehen und das ist
eigentlich also letztlich egal wie
einseitig ist vielleicht produziert sein
mag ist je nachdem aus welcher
perspektive man das dann betrachtet
eröffnet ist ein diskurs der auch nicht
nur junge leute betrifft also es wird ja
jetzt auch immer viel gesagt dass das
jetzt junge leute sind jetzt auf einmal
sich für politik interessieren oder die
durch die freitags von future bewegung
schon er politisiert werden und da jetzt
noch mal an
quasi angesprochen werden aber wenn man
sich die kommentare ein bisschen
anschaut sieht man ja auch dass ganz
viel um inter generation ahlen diskurs
geht und dass auch viele nicht zu der
jungen zielgruppe gehörende personen
eben sich dort mit den inhalten die wiso
präsentiert hat auseinandersetzen und
das ist eigentlich ganz großartig wie
stehen sie denn zur aussage von
cdu-generalsekretär merkt dass sich die
medien mal gedanken machen sollen also
auch wir warum sich junge leute bei riis
so informieren und nicht mehr bei ihnen
und bei uns es ist eine große konkurrenz
für klassische medienunternehmen
geworden also wir wissen dass irgendwie
etwas mehr als die hälfte der jungen
menschen sich über soziale medien auch
ihre nachrichten suchen gleichzeitig
stehen sie aber in dem konflikt dass sie
diese nicht so ganz vertrauenswürdig
einschätzen wie jetzt die medien die in
den klassischen häusern produziert
werden aber je größer oder ja ja doch je
größer die infrastrukturen eigentlich
sind die dahinter stehen um so schwer
wiegen ihre schwer weniger sind ja
letztlich auch die prozesse allerdings
reagieren ja auch unterschiedliche
medienhäuser damit dass sie in sozialen
medien aktiv sind und ihm auch sehr
kurzfristig inhalte produzieren können
eine interessante analyse vielen da
eigentlich jude ackermann
danke